[Applaudissements]
n'était il était extrêmement sympathique
il paraît que vous avez eu un fou rire
un jour en tirer non les fous rires on
en arrive à les ja musab à un moment
vous êtes 10 watts à ces jeux se situe
en direct dans les guignols
j'aurais pu la voir mais il y avait
quand même il fallait se tenir mais
aussi de rire de ce soir donc il fallait
que ce soit ça paraît sérieux m'est
arrivé de me tromper de voie des choses
comme ça mais le fou rire on l'a
toujours évité il a déjà essayé de
contacter les guignols pour leur dire
voilà vous en faites trop ou peut-être
pas mais non je pense que lui justement
c'est pour ça que je les salue à la fin
de son règne avait à dire parce que je
ne voulais pas de rapports amicaux avec
lui tout du long
ça a été ma priorité et je suis allé le
voir pour lui dire en quelque sorte
merci de nous avoir foutu la paix parce
que il nous a justement jamais dieu sait
si ses collaborateurs certains plus
petit que lui qui disait monsieur chirac
faut arrêter volet s'arrêter et
répondait laisser l'est ce sont des
enfants et donc c max et et ça c'est
qu'ils prenaient pour des gosses qu'on
était en étaient des sales gosses mais
c'était ça